ça y est epicure ya un an
c'est vous et grâce à vos messages vos
questions vos partages qui avait rendu
possible le succès des piqûres yeux
alors pour vous remercier de votre
fidélité
je vous invite sur le tournage de l'une
de mes vidéos pour tenter votre chance
c'est très simple il suffit d'inscrire
en commentaire avec qui vous souhaitez
vivre cette expérience et pour maximiser
nos chances sachez vous pouvez
participer sur facebook instagram tictoc
youtube short partout cette vidéo est
postée j'ai hâte de vous rencontrer et
pour tous les autres
rassurez-vous de nombreuses surprises
arrivent ce répit curieux croyez moi
cette deuxième année ça va être du
gâteau